you
[Music]
was to be as long as there's a Heartland
will not the Apollo what you brought a
singer talented maybe we'll go see him
sometime oscar-winning actor Forrest
Whitaker has won critical acclaim for
incredibly diverse roles in a career
that spanned decades in his latest he
plays a real but little-known crime
kingpin who's life intersected with some
fascinating historical figures The
Godfather of Harlem debuts tomorrow on
Epic's we sat down with Whitaker and
Harlem to talk about it and how he's
hoping to leave his mark
beyond acting columns mine
times have changed in his newest role
Forest Whitaker brings the heat how does
it feel to be on television I mean
you're a movie star a movie star but far
from acting like one
I felt like I was making a independent
film yeah yeah I will shut down all your
spots just like a DD Whitaker is both
actor and executive producer and the new
epic series Godfather of Harlem cut it
out
he's made it's a real-life story of
gangster Ellsworth bumpy Johnson who
ruled Harlem from the 1930s to the 1960s
as an associate of Charles Lucky Luciano
this is bumpy Johnson he's a legend
Johnson was a crime boss who wasn't
always what he seemed runs the sort of
crime scene including numbers running
drugs but he's also deep family man he's
a poet
he's a chess player he's complicated one
hand he's this crime lord who did all
these things in the city in the city and
on another he's somebody who like sends
people to college and tries to make sure
the people's lives were better oh and
Charlie you just got in the Morehouse a
little short on funds but you
Johnson's been fictionalized before I
don't know why you make me come to these
things to culture you bumpy but this
time viewers see an older version just
new you'll get right back into the swing
of things
after a decade behind bars for drug
conspiracy he's out now he's trying to
figure out who's taking over his
territories how I can get them back what
the maneuvers are gonna be the
strategies and how I can keep himself
safe and alive nothing goes down from
110 to 160th unless I get my car
he's juxtaposed against two very famous
other characters Malcolm X hmm and Adam
Clayton Powell the politician right
hello Evan Powell it's been a long time
Johnson welcome back yeah I mean I think
you said you couldn't make this stuff I
know is this too when you see it I mean
when you find out about it he grew up in
the the crime world mmm with Malcolm X
yeah well Malcolm X was you know when he
was Detroit Red before when he was you
know running numbers himself and doing a
number of difficult things and they
became friends I guess during that time
oppa Johnson Detroit Red
[Music]
force winokur's big break was as the
brawny football jock in Fast Times at
Ridgemont High but with every new film
he broke ground and the taboos of the
times she's my top most notably is the
lover of a transgender woman in 1992's
The Crying Game and fanatical Ugandan
dictator Idi Amin in The Last King of
Scotland which earned him an Oscar but
producing is where he thinks he can make
a greater impact along with partner Nina
yang bon jovi he founded significant
productions in 2010 okay so it's helped
to increase diversity in Hollywood with
films like Fruitvale station mom
an indie breakout sorry to bother you
hello hi mrs. Costello people connect to
a story they connect to a character and
ultimately they can connect to a
cultural people yeah the more specific
you are to think culture the more the
more Universal the stories start to
become because we've never had a
financially unsuccessful film I think
all of our films have been at Sundance
like three of them of one of them indie
cons so we've been really unfortunate to
these little films but but with
filmmakers that make a difference but
the biggest difference Whitaker hopes to
make is through the Whitaker peace and
development initiative where global
citizens are empowered to use peaceful
conflict resolution a global change
agent that tilt hundreds of thousands in
Africa and Mexico build small businesses
and bridges toward peace imagine war as
the only reality you ever known
it was inspired by a child soldier he
met in Uganda she had been a child
soldier with a lot of harmful things to
others was ostracized by the community
would have to live in the community she
had no place to go
she's just in this Hut and I mean we're
talking to her and saying you know what
can we do I brought our voice back to
the UN and they heard that then I
decided you know I have to do something
on the ground you know they make a
change now that he's living part of the
year filming his new series in Harlem
his fans have a bit more access to show
their love Vegas
humble as ever Whitaker still feels he's
got a lot left to learn what sometimes I
think I'm too old to be like not having
answers you know I mean III should have
better answers I should know what to do
I keep making the same mistakes
sometimes hopefully the next look will
be a little a little different you know
twist and turn its way to something even
more important more connected you don't
feel important or connect I mean I think
of important things I think more about
like the issues with humanity and like
the connections that we all have as
people to be able to be one like Desmond
Tutu has talked about it when he says
do your little bits of good where you
are and all those little bits of good
will overwhelm the world I want to be a
part of that because a little bit so so
full so sweet
such a great guy I remember him in bird
where he played Charlie Parker that he
learned how to play the sax for that you
know his origins are in music you want a
scholarship a USC's music school for
them was discovered by an agent
his next film he's going to showcase
some of that vocal talent oh good you
know in a movie on Netflix called jingle
jangle so it's so interesting about his
voice because he speaks it like this
level right but but you it's so serious
until you see it at this level and
you're like you're you're moved in I
mean you just kind of go in to listen I
mean you really hear him I love that
humanity side of him with all that money
and power he wants to give back he wants
to do good so you good man looking
forward to checking it out